[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight this election is coming up fast
faster than you may realize how fast
well six months from tomorrow the
leadership of the Democratic Party will
gather on the floor of a basketball
arena in Milwaukee and formally nominate
their presidential candidate now at this
point as of right now there's a strong
chance that nominee will be Bernie
Sanders if that happens if Sanders
becomes the official leader of the
Democratic Party there will be chaos the
party's funders on Wall Street will
recoil in terror at what's to come
they'll be joined in that terror by the
establishment class in New York and Los
Angeles as well as by the entire in
telling foreign policy bureaucracies in
Washington and all of them all of these
people demand to know one thing how this
happened how did Bernie Sanders become
the Democratic nominee and that's a good
question here's part of the answer it
all started last night at the democratic
debate in Des Moines when CNN president
Jeff Zucker decided to destroy the
Sanders for president campaign now
Zurcher poses as a television executive
but he operates like a political
consultant his latest client is the
Democratic establishment which has
dispatched him to crush Bernie Sanders
before he can take control of the party
so just before last night's debate
CNN ran a story claiming without any
proof at all that Bernie Sanders had
once told Elizabeth Warren that a woman
could not be president Sanders denied
that charge vigorously but the message
was unmistakable and crystal clear he's
a sexist don't vote for him
CNN relentlessly hyped the allegations
on air and then once again during the
debate watch how suckers hand-selected
moderator framed the story
I do want to be clear here you're saying
that you never told senator Warren that
a woman could not win the election that
is correct senator Warren what did you
think when senator Sanders told you a
woman could not win the election I
disagreed senator Warren what did you
think when senator Sanders told you a
woman could not win the election which
he clearly did because he's old and
hates women and also lies a lot
just weren't journalism from our friends
on cable news suddenly in weed sensitive
part Minh surround Brooklyn in the Bay
Area legions of Bernie supporters
understood for the very first time why
Donald Trump is always attacking CNN why
because CNN deserves it and thousands of
them reach for their credit cards in
response by this morning the Sanders
campaign was reporting its best ever
fundraising on a debate day with more
than a hundred thousand individual
donations so it turns out it's possible
to level attacks that are so stupid and
so unfair that they wind up helping the
person you're trying to hurt that's the
lesson CNN has repeatedly failed to
learn in the trump era and they were no
smarter this time from within
Jeff suckers dark and airless bubble
everything seemed to be going precisely
according to plan Sanders look a lot of
it's personal preference I didn't think
his answer visa vie Elizabeth Warren and
what was said in that conversation was
particularly good he was largely
dismissible I didn't say it everybody
knows I didn't say it we don't need to
talk about it and I think what Bernie
forgot was that the season if he said
she said story this is a reported out
story that CNN was part of breaking so
to have him just flat-out say no I think
wasn't wasn't nearly enough to address
that for the women watching and I can't
imagine any woman watching last night
and saying
I believe Bernie I think people believe
Elizabeth this was Elizabeth Warren
tonight she need to do something and
there was a banana peel sitting out
there for Bernie to step on when it came
to his comments about women I think
Bernie stepped on and slid around she
knocked that moment out of the park Oh
CNN it's a world where buffoonish old
Joe Lockhart mustard stains on his shirt
is suddenly a renowned expert on what
women really
what hilarious ask his first wife but no
one in Zucker land thought it was funny
at all they had their orders they
proceeded to carry them out with grim
determination onward to battle Bertie
must be stopped it almost seemed
personal and in some ways it was
personal just four days ago CNN settled
a lawsuit with its unionized employees
for a record 76 million dollars it was
the single largest payout ever collected
in the 84 year history of the National
Labor Relations Board when that deal was
announced Bernie Sanders issued a
statement celebrating the win for CNN's
oppressed and miserable workforce and
they are trust me
quote congratulations to the
Communication Workers of America for
this victory this is the result of the
union fighting for years to get these
workers the Justice they deserve end
quote
Jeff Zucker was not amused by that he
readied his troops for battle but in the
end it didn't work and by the way it
won't work Americans may dislike
politicians but they hate the media more
if forced to choose between Bernie
Sanders and CNN most people will go with
Bernie